hey how's it going Wolfgang the Avengers
fought with all of their might in
Avengers infinity war but it was not
enough to stop the mad Titan Thanos
unfortunately he was just too strong for
the Avengers
he was already insanely strong on his
own defeating the Hulk in the beginning
of the movie without the help of any of
the Infinity stones but throughout the
movie he collected more and more
Infinity stones becoming more and more
powerful with each stone that he got
Thanos was just too powerful for the
Avengers was
now reality can be whatever he collected
all of the Infinity stones put them all
on his Infinity Gauntlet Inc
successfully completed his snap and then
unfortunately we had to watch all of our
favourite heroes disintegrate quick
reminder if you want to be able to watch
infinity war over and over and over
again be sure to enter my giveaway I'll
be giving away a few copies on blu-ray
all you have to do to enter is subscribe
to my channel like this video and
comment below with your favorite
superhero so something happened when
Thanos completed his snap that is both
good news and bad news for the Avengers
when Thanos completed his snap both him
and the Infinity Gauntlet were
permanently damaged this has been
confirmed by the directors the Russo
brothers themselves this was given to us
in the Infinity war commentary in the
scene where Thanos comes back from
talking to baby Gamora which is believed
to be so world you can see him and Thor
both looking at the Infinity Gauntlet
and it is clearly really damaged and in
the scene Joe Russo says this see there
with his gauntlet and the arm the power
that it takes to use all six stones is
significant and clearly damage the
gauntlet and damage Thanos permanently
so here's the thing about the Infinity
stones that everybody should know they
are extremely powerful
[Music]
so powerful that an ordinary being
cannot hold an infinity stone without
essentially being vaporized
Thanos being as strong as he is can
actually hold Infinity stones with his
bare hands and he can probably use the
power of one of them on his own but
using all of them well that's just too
powerful and he himself knows that which
is why he has Eitri make him the
Infinity Gauntlet
but clearly using all of the power of
the Infinity stones at once was even too
powerful for the Infinity Gauntlet it
not only damaged the gauntlet but it
also damaged him he has major burns and
scars on his left arm
however the Infinity Gauntlet is not
completely broken we know this because
he uses the space stone to teleport away
from the Avengers and to go to his
little Hut we then see him limping as he
goes to sit down showing the damage that
has been caused because of the snap so
although the Infinity Gauntlet may work
with just a single stone it's highly
unlikely that it could handle another
snap not only that but Thanos probably
couldn't handle another one as well so
with the Infinity Gauntlet and Thanos
both being permanently damaged as I said
before this is both good and bad news
good news because well Thanos is hurt
and that's good news that'll probably
make him easier to defeat it cost
[Music]
and good news because with the Infinity
Gauntlet damaged he can't use the power
of all of the stones at once so now they
actually have a chance against him but
the bad news is they can't use the
gauntlet to undo the snap now so this of
course now explains why the Avengers
have to figure out some way to go back
in time to undo the snap there's plenty
of things that they can do with time
travel such as go back in time visit
Eitri have him Forge them their own
Infinity Gauntlet then come back to the
present and take the stones from Thanos
however what is more probable is that
they will go back in time and collect
the Infinity stones for themselves that
way they wouldn't actually have to fight
Thanos who has all the Infinity stones
currently they could just do their own
snap which could undo Thanos to snap and
then use the Infinity stones to defeat
Thanos but that is just one of the many
ways that it could go in Avengers 4 what
do you all think about this new
information that the gauntlet is
permanently damaged along with Thanos
and how do you think they're going to
use time travel and Avengers 4 let me
know your thoughts in the comments below
and just another reminder about my
giveaway of Avengers infinity war on
blu-ray all you have to do to enter is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment below with your favorite
superhero thank you so much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]